reportage carreau d'une colique fabuleos
il est 5 heures du matin jared kiss ou
traversent les rues désertées de
georgetown la capitale du guyana pour se
rendre sur son lieu de travail un trajet
de trois heures c'est l'unique accès un
jazz charme depuis la côte ouest il ya
toujours beaucoup de circulation
après une heure de route jared arrive
dans la vie de paracas située sur le
fleuve et ses kibo ils échangent sa
voiture contre un taxi bateau
la traversée du fleuve dure une
demi-heure c'est le moyen le plus rapide
pour atteindre à la côte ouest du pays
une fois arrivés dans la ville de super
nam sur l'autre rive de laisser kibo il
reprend la route
pendant une heure ils traversent les
rizières et plusieurs communes avant de
retrouver la vie de charity situé sur
l'autre fleuve le premier round
après 30 minutes de navigation jared
kissoun arrive enfin sur son lieu de
travail une plantation de noix de coco
de plus de 300 hectares elle porte le
nom du fleuve qui est l'unique moyen
d'accès jared rats présentent les
investisseurs étrangers qui ont loué ses
terres pendant 50 ans pour planter de la
noix de coco
gary grant et l'agriculture diplômés et
gérard de la plantation
ils échangent sur l'avancée du projet un
investissement de 3 millions d'euros
25000 cocotiers nord pousse dans la
nursery ces arbres à présent de l'avenir
de cette entreprise qui veut faire
l'exportation d'eau de coco c'est une
variété 18 développé pour la production
de los cocos
nous sommes fiers parce qu une nursery
de cette superficie n'existe nulle part
dans la caraïbe j'ai sélectionné des
plantes mères de qualité chez plusieurs
agriculteurs
je les ai amenés dans la nurserie pour
les faire penser ainsi nous aurons des
arbres de qualité une capacité cette
exploitation va reconduire 18 millions
de noirs
au fond de cet immense exploitation se
trouve un champ planté de 5000 jeunes
cocotier en attendons la première
récolte prévue dans deux ans une méthode
de culture mixte sert à pratiquer nous
avons laissé de l'espace sur les
plates-bandes vous planter du curcuma du
gingembre de la march est là bronzé et
des cerisiers entre les cocotiers cette
culture mixte va aider à régénérer les
sols et près des revenus supplémentaires
dont l'exploitation pour financer les
opérations
ce tracteur a été transportée par le
fleuve ici afin d'accélérer les travaux
ici je fais une plate-bande je vais
commencer
ok vas-y la noix de coco est cultivé sur
cette plantation depuis deux siècles ces
grands arbres ont plus de 80 ans
elles ne sont plus productifs ils
doivent tous être remplacé l'opérateur
cette variété de grandes pacifique mais
faire de la place pour planter nicotine
est aussitôt le terrain préparé les
ouvriers agricoles plantes de jeunes
cocotiers n'a une cinquantaine de
salariés travaillent ici les jeunes
arbres sont traitées contre la carrière
rouge du panier un parasite qui a fait
des ravages dont les cocoteraies du
guyana les jeunes arbres dans la
mercerie qui vont porter dans trois ans
sont traitées avant d'implanter avec là
bas mais qd il ça nous aide à contrôler
la carrière rouge du palmier aucun
cocotier mais planté sans être traité au
préalable dans la nursery
cette plantation a été quasiment laissé
à l'abandon par son propriétaire
l'une des vieilles familles du guyana
les héritiers ont signé le bail pourrait
démarrer l'exploitation des terres sur
lesquelles quelques ouvriers et leurs
familles sont encore logés dont ces
cabanes en bois
l'ancienne activité la cueillette des
noix de coco sec continue
les noirs sont séparés en deux
catégories les plus belles vont au
marché
les spécimens inférieures seront
transformés en coprah et l'huile de
cuisine animés quasi l'argent facile
qu'elle tombe des armes
pas besoin de les contacter en les
ramassant terre sous les arbres nous
employés sont rémunérés à la noix peu
importe si elle sera vendue sur le
marché ou pour fabriquer le coprah les
revenus contribuer aux opérations
on cultive les meilleurs noix de coco du
guyana sur les rivages du fleuve comme
et rooney la mer est proche et les
cocotiers prolifèrent dans des sols
irrigué par l'eau saumâtre leur forme
située sur le fleuve est une
exploitation agricole de 15 hectares où
on cultive des noix de coco depuis des
décennies vima de siva la propriétaire
accède au chaud pas un petit bateau à
travers un réseau des canalisations
[Musique]
tu vois les cocotiers
c'est cocoteraie sont bien nettoyer ces
arbres en bonne santé
ça fait des années que madame de sylvain
a entamé un programme pour remplacer les
vieux arbres la noix de coco a toujours
été là record de phares de son
exploitation 35 ouvriers agricoles
travaillent à nda ce que j'aime avec la
noix de coco c'est que c'est une plante
qui est résistante
c'est le seul arbre qui chaque mois
donnent des fruits
c'est une banque on peut obtenir de
l'argent chaque mois on va aux arbres et
nous donne de l'argent chaque mois au
fond de la plantation se trouvent des
champs de coco n'a quand le propriétaire
arrive elle veut vérifier la qualité de
son eau de coco
il est facile de récolter les fruits des
cocotiers n'a les grappes sont sécurisés
par un crochet après quelques coups de
coutelas les jeunes coco sont
soigneusement posé par terre un
atterrissage trop brutale et les cocos
peuvent éclater
il faut compter le nombre de noix de
coco récoltés dans chaque abri cette
variété de cocotiers na est réputé pour
sa générosité
j'ai étudié toutes les variétés de
cocotiers j'ai trouvé que ce nazaire est
le meilleur quand on a une invasion de
la mite rouge tous les armes ont été
infectées mais pas le navet donc j'ai
décidé de continuer de planter l'eau est
excellente et chaque mois un arbre ne
donne entre 25 et 30 mois chaque mois
villemade svara code 40000 noah qui
seront utilisés pour l'eau et 10000 coco
sec qui seront transformés en huile
chaque semaine des milliers de noix de
coco sont transportés dans cette usine
située à une trentaine de minutes des
cocoteraies de pomérols à l'eau des
seynois sera mise en bouteille elles
sont lavées à haute pression
les noix tombe dans un bac métalliques
remplies d'eau de javel
il faut éliminer la saleté et les
bactéries
dans une autre pièce les bouteilles qui
vont réceptionner cette eau sont en
préparation les bouteilles sont
désinfectés à la vapeur
la chaleur sert également à coller les
étiquettes
aujourd'hui c'est en chaîne orange le
plus grand vendeur d'eau de coco à
trinidad-et-tobago qui utilisent les
usines pour embouteiller l'eau du guyana
avec l'étiquetage de son entreprise fait
dix ans que je vole au secours ici je
rousies que celle de guyane est la
meilleure que je n'ai jamais hésité
c'est parce que c'est la réalité
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
qui trinidad et que je viens ici tous
faire ma production en guyane avant
d'accéder au sein de transformation les
employés doivent au filet des blues des
gants et des bottes stérilisés ils
doivent couvrir leur tête la salle de
découpage et climatisés pour réduire
toute possibilité de contamination les
noix de coco son coupé l'eau est filtrée
dans des seaux métalliques les noirs
vider son j'étais à l'extérieur du
bâtiment
la cadence est infernale
les sont remplies de l'eau de coco passe
par cette petite fenêtre de l'autre côté
l'eau est versé dans ce réservoir
métallique refroidi par de la glace
la mise en bouteille se fait
manuellement
cette eau ne contient aucun produit de
conservation elle n'est pas pasteurisé
avec la chaleur les bouter sont
encapsulés l'étiquetage dans chan
marange comporte le numéro du lot et la
date de péremption
les gens veulent voir de l'autre côté il
veut qu'elle constitue naturellement
sucré et c'est ça que le but n en
propose et que nous n'avons pas un
tribunal
les bouteilles sont collectées dans ces
sacs roses et transféraient dans un
conteneur de congélation de 20 pieds en
chan barrage à cinq jours pour le
remplir avec treize mille litres de
l'eau de coco avant de l'expédier pas
bateau acciona d'art et tobago
jack ingram le gère les opérations de
l'usiné depuis son bureau elle suit
chaque étape des opérations
cette structure la plus grande de ce
type au guyana ap anciens en entreprise
privée appelée russes 2
la compagnie embauche 15 personnes le
salaire est de 200 euros pour quinze
jours de travail assuré la chaîne deux
fois coûte cher la facture d'électricité
s'élève à 500 euros par mois contre eau
de coco ne contient aucun conservateur
elle est naturelle de la noix de coco à
la bouteille
une contamination est facile donc il
faut faire très attention avec ce que
nous faisons
à
il y à plus de 1400 cultivateurs de noix
de coco au guyana la majorité sont des
petits planteurs
tous ont été frappées par l'effondrement
dimanche et en 1994 à cause d'un rapport
américain qui affirmait que lui de la
noix de coco était dangereuse pour la
santé
depuis des cocoteraies ont été laissés à
l'abandon
remplacé par des rizières au guyana on
va chercher des noix de coco compte il
ya une commande pour l'huile et pour le
coprah ces deux ouvriers cueille des
noix pour en particulier ils ne veulent
plus grimper dans des arbres pour
récolter les fruits grimper aux arbres
il y avait des cerveaux des manic
c'est pour cela que j'utilise cette
langue de tracteurs qui laboure les
rivières je la tâche à une rouge de
bambou je cueille et comme ça je
n'aurais plus son coéquipier qui
décortiquait les cocos estime que ce
travail n'est pas valorisant en plus il
est mal rémunéré il reçoit 15 euros pour
une centaine de noix de coco
la nouvelle demande mondiale pour ce
produit ne l'inspirent part pour être
honnête ce n'est pas de travail agréable
pas pour les jeunes il faut qu'ils
aillent à l'école qu'ils poursuivent
leurs études et qu'il trouve un vrai
travail
à naryn l'institut national pour la
recherche agricole située sur la côte
est du guyana on veut encourager les
plantes à réhabiliter les cocoteraies le
dr wood aux menottes et directeur
général en arts ea l'organisation
intervient sur tout le territoire du
guyana dont tous les secteurs
d'agriculture doté d'une subvention
annuelle de seulement cinq cent mille
euros
narry ne peut pas proposer des aides
financières aux planteurs de noix de
coco en cas d'infestation de la mite
rouge du palmier par exemple le
gouvernement interviendra pour fournir
des produits phytosanitaires
gratuitement sur ce type d'intervention
oui mais je ne demande pas de
subventions sauf si elles font partie
d'un projet nous n'avons pas ce système
au guyana sauf si vous allez à la banque
analyse ce kit et scientifique de
recherche a narré scolarisés à cuba elle
a obtenu un master à l'université de
yucatan au mexique ça tu as porté sur le
protocole d'importation et d'exportation
des noix de coco re bonjour je vous
présente mes enfants c'est 69 jeunes
cocotiers qui pousse dans la news
rihanna riz sont tous ceux qui restent
des 450 qu'elle avait importé depuis le
mexique pour compléter sa thèse je
faisais l'expérience mexique et j'ai
obtenu un taux de survie de 100%
donc c'est une déception mais nous
sommes toujours contents d'avoir un
représentant de chaque variété expédiés
depuis le mexique les toits variété de
noix de coco sélectionnés par analyse ce
kit sont utilisés pour la production de
l'eau de coco et de l'huile elle compte
bien mener son expérience à terme ces
plantes pourrait bien sauver le secteur
d'une maladie catastrophique
la raison principale pour l'introduction
de ces variétés c'est qu'elles ont un
rendement élevé
elles sont résistantes au jaunissement
mortelle du palmier qui frappe les noix
de coco en amérique latine et aux
caraïbes
la maladie n'a pas été confirmée au
ghana mais aussi près par l'unique
méthode de combattre cette maladie est
d'utiliser les variétés résistantes
il n'existe pas d'autre remède à cette
maladie la ville de glendale et située à
deux heures de route au sud de la
capitale georgetown owen de souza
plantes les noix de coco sur les quatre
hectares du terrain familial depuis
trente ans il en cultive cette variété
il connaît les utilisations de chacune
voici le guyana baisse
elle produit à partir de 5 ans elle est
bonne pour fabriquer de l'huile elle est
généreuse et voici la hchouma qui donne
à partir de 3 ans les noix sont sucrés
le monde entier aiment seynois je dis
bien le monde entier tout le monde aime
sept mois aujourd'hui le docteur rabat
biotechnologies c'est avec cardy
l'institut de carhaix bien de recherche
et de développement agricole lui rend
visite
candy a bénéficié d'une subvention de
3,5 millions d'euros de l'union
européenne pour aider à la
réhabilitation des noix de coco dans 9
pays de la caraïbe
le programme s'étale sur trois ans owen
da souza fait partie des dix planteurs
sélectionné au guyana pour était un bien
les nuances rider noix de coco on lui a
fourni de la matière première
il peut vendre ses plantes aux
cultivateurs qui veulent redémarrer dans
le secteur le planteur ne reçoit pas
d'argent
il obtient du matériel pour travailler
pour préparer son terrain pour l'engrais
du matériel pour l'irrigation et des
canalisations tous les planteurs qui
participe à son programme pour établir
les merceries ont reçu plusieurs
variétés de nos germe place
donc nous allons protéger une gêne ou
plasma danse énergie que nous ne voulons
pas perdre nos variétés dans ce bâtiment
inachevé owen da souza savait que de
l'huile de noix de coco et 27 différence
avant selon des recettes de sa grand
mère
aujourd'hui il fabrique un savon à base
de papaye d'aloe vera et d'huile de noix
de coco ils utilisent des appareils
domestiques pour mélanger ces
ingrédients
ces savants sont riches en lui de coco
vierge
ils sont parfumés avec des huiles
essentielles
ça vaut font éclater le town la peau à
jeûner de 10 ans le ca vaut parle pour
lui même je ne peux pas trop en parler
le savon et son propre témoin
owen d'souza ce qu'on tente d'écouler
ces savants sur la manche et locales
hallandale il pense souvent à
l'intérieur du pays pour vendre aux
clients qui travaillent dans des mines
d'or
le manque d'appareils industriel
freinent l'expansion de cette fabrique
de savon et d'huile de noix de coco j'ai
de la matière première la noix de coco
mais je n'ai pas d'outil je n'ai pas
d'argent pour acheter des appareils
donc je fais des choses d'une manière
simple je ne veux pas d'emprunts
bancaires parce que ma marge est assez
réduite
donc après n'est pas une bonne idée je
veux une aide ou trouver un investisseur
pour mon entreprise
la gmc comparation du marketing du
guyana a présenté 80 fabricants de
produits transformés
la mission de la coopération et des ces
fabricants de produits made in ghana a
déniché les marchés externes
ce magasin à georgetown eu lieu
fréquenté par les visiteurs et les
locaux est une vitrine pour ses
producteurs
il y a des cosmétiques à base d'huile de
noix de coco
plusieurs marques d'huile de coco
comestibles il ya aussi une marque
locale de lait et crème de coco en boîte
à idées s'il y a des nz et la
responsable du marketing à la gmc
elle est frustrée par le manque de
visibilité des produits transformés du
guyana à l'étranger la question qu'on se
pose c'est est ce qu'il existe des
opportunités pour nous d'augmenter notre
capacité pour transformer la noix de
coco
on pourrait développer une stratégie
pour promouvoir nos produits dans des
marchés spécialisés des produits avec
moins d'ingrédients artificiels sans
conservateur vendus aux gens qui
s'occupent de leur santé on pourrait
commencer avec les produits de santé et
de beauté
il y a quinze ans mason a quitté la
chine pour le guyanais
elle travaillait d'abord pour une
compagnie chinoise d'exportation
aujourd'hui elle fabrique des produits à
base de noix de coco qui sont vendus
dans des supermarchés du guyana elle
fait de l'huile pressée à froid sa
farine à base de noix de coco est la
seule sur le marché
c'est un produit avec du potentiel de
taranis me faro guyana on utilise la
farine de noix de coco pour faire des
biscuits mais le cowboy difficile à
rapper avec cette farine on peut faire
des biscuits et des gâteaux ça très bon
mais une bonne saveur
je veux commercialiser un mélange à
biscuits et à mélange à gâteau
[Musique]
vous
le garage de sa maison sert de lieu de
production et d'expérimentation
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'elle innove et met au point
de nouvelles techniques
elle a inventé dérape électrique pour
extraire a lâché en de la noix de coco
elles n'embauchent que des femmes qui
gagnent 68 euros par semaine ces
machines facilite le travail lâche à
rapper et sécher dans ce four une autre
invention de mason
cette méthode axel à la production elle
veut vendre ses produits sur les marchés
nord-américains pour les marchés à
l'étranger il y a beaucoup de normes à
respecter pour obtenir un agrément
sanitaire
donc notre prochaine étape c'est la
certification iso 9001 et nous voulons
plus d'équipements pour augmenter notre
production
cette petite usine de transformer que
200 noix de coco par jour car la chaîne
de production et laborieuse une fois
séchés la chair est placé dans cette
presse hydraulique
le produit final l'huile de noix de coco
extraite à foix cool dont le saut c'est
beaucoup de travail pour fabriquer
l'huile et notre marché local est petit
il faut pénétrer les marchés à
l'étranger mais on a besoin
d'investissements
parfois je veux tout arrêter parce que
je ne gagne pas d'argent et je reçois
des appels des gens qui me disent que
l'on produit les a aidés
donc ce n'est pas seulement une question
d'argent simon produit peut aider
pourquoi ne pas continuer bénissant cas
ingénieur agronome est l'un des plus
grands propriétaires terriens au guyana
il y a cinq ans avec un apport de 100
mille dollars
il a fondé cette compagnie avec mason
pour développer l'exportation des
produits transformés à base de la noix
de coco la matière première vient de ces
cocoteraie dénis cinq ans craignent que
la nouvelle découverte de pétrole en
guyana détruisent le secteur agricole
elle manie l'argent du pétrole fera du
bien en guyane a peut-être qu'on
n'obtiendra pas tous les revenus espérés
mais ce que je souhaite c'est que le
gouvernement utilise cet argent pour
construire des infrastructures pour
investir dans l'éducation la sécurité la
santé et permettre aux gens ordinaires
de cultiver la terre les aider et
financer les organisations
gouvernementales d'agriculture pour
qu'elles puissent accomplir leur mission
[Musique]
selon le gouvernement du guyana la
recette de la manne pétrolière vont
transformer le pays dont la pittoresque
capital georgetown
la population attend les premières et
tomber d'ici 2020
le quia n'en est d'abord un pays
agricole située en dehors de la zone
cyclonique
aujourd'hui le marché mondial de noix de
coco s'élève à 6 milliards de dollars
par an dont le guyanais ne touche que 5
millions seules les banques commerciales
qui prêtent à des taux élevés offrent
des financements aux planteurs et au
agroindustrial en l'absence d' aide
l'industrie de la noix de coco ne peut
pas se développer un vendeur d'eau de
coco touche 80 centimes d'euro par noah
or à l'étranger le contenu du noix de
coco se vendent à 5 euros
seuls les gros investisseurs privés du
guyana pourront tirer profit de
l'expansion actuelle du marché mondial
de la noix de coco